I was disappointed that you were not
going to be able to make Star Trek
um I I had heard through the grapevine
that the script was coming together uh
and I'm just curious have you actually
said what your movie was going to be
about no I haven't you know and I think
I'm probably not really allowed to speak
too much about it because I think what
they're still working on is a a version
of what I had been working on for the
time that I was involved so my thing I'm
a huge Star Trek fan but I actually and
I want to talk honestly about this I
actually think that making a Star Trek
movie for a hundred or 150 million
dollars I don't actually know if it's
going to work anymore and I say it
because there's a finite
um like the the movies don't tend to
perform at these huge numbers at the box
office and I'm wondering it was the
movie you were considering without
spoilers was it one of those where it
was going to cost like 150 100 million
dollars like a ton of money it part two
of this is because I actually think that
the way forward on a Star Trek movie is
maybe to make one that's like 30 to 50
million that's hard sci-fi aimed right
at the fans and if it gets other people
great
it's an interesting question you know I
think um in our day and age now anytime
you go to space in a movie it's
expensive and when you're flying around
in the Enterprise even if you're going
to land and be in one place for a long
time it's still pretty expensive you
have a large cast as well many of whom
are really you know well known as
because they're amazing and
um and so just bringing that group
together again isn't a cheap you know uh
event so I think yes the movie that I
was planning to make was going to be a a
large tentpole film you know and I think
that one of the things that JJ has done
so well is that you know he'll be the
first to admit he wasn't um he didn't
grow up being a giant Star Trek fan even
though he's a fan now but he he was a
huge Star Wars fan and so I think in
rebooting it with Chris Pine and Zoe and
and Zach he
um brought a little bit of Star Wars to
it which I think helped expand its
audience you know in terms of
um the scope and the scale of it and the
energy of it and so I think that you
know that certainly is is the goal is
that to find more and more more of an
audience for Star Trek but I am like you
a huge fan of that
um and it was a real shame that yeah I
couldn't make the timing work on it